it was a somber scene last night at an
LA restaurant as Hef's four children
came together for a quiet family meal to
remember their father and the infamous
playground he called home for nearly 50
years the new owners are close friends
and if you walk around here you know
nothing has really changed
that's half son Cooper last year after
the estate sold for 100 million dollars
to Darrin metropolis halves next-door
neighbor mansion regular and heir to a
multi-billion dollar fortune built by
Pabst Blue Ribbon beer and hostess
Twinkies a source tells eat team
metropolis plans to restore the property
to its original 1927 design and connect
the estate to his so called sister house
next door you know you had a fun night
when you wake up in the monkey cage out
of respect for Hef's love of animals his
exotic menagerie will stay and the
mansion known for its legendary parties
will host one more
a celebration of Hefner's legacy and
hospitality in Casablanca everybody
comes to Rick's well the reality is
they're pretty everybody comes to the
Playboy Mansion
[Music]
you